the media lose their mind over a former
FBI director james comey 'he's new book
cory booker makes a complete ass of
himself and we checked the mailbag i'm
ben shapiro and this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
some days you get up in the morning
you're just giddy to do the show because
I mean let's be real this news cycle is
um is balls it's incredible and there's
so much to talk about from slime ball to
pee tapes to Cory Booker who apparently
is weirdly obsessed with gay sex and
it's and its various permutations so
many things to talk about in the news
but first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at helix sleep so right
now you're probably not getting enough
sleep one of the reasons you're not
getting enough sleep is because you are
not sleeping on a helix sleep mattress
working with the world's leading sleep
expert helix sleep developed a mattress
that is customized just your specific
height weight and sleep preferences so
you can have the best sleep of your life
at an unbeatable price so here's how it
works you go to helix sleep calm you
fill out their two minutes sleep quiz
and they will design your custom
mattress they can even customize each
side for you and a partner and in 2018
helix sleep has taken customized sleep
to the next level they have the helix
pillow butter almond pills are fully
adjustable so you can achieve perfect
comfort regardless of sleep position or
body type helix sleep has thousands of
five-star reviews plus you get a hundred
nights to try them out
if you don't like it then they'll take
it back go to helix loop comm slash Ben
right now and get up to 125 bucks toward
your mattress order that's helix sleep
comm slash Ben's he get 125 dollars
again off your mattress order helix
sleep comm slash Ben and you get that
special deal again use that slash Ben so
that they know that we sent you their
mattresses are terrific there's a reason
that I sleep better at home that I sleep
on the road one of them is that helix
sleep mattress is what's underneath me
when I am sleeping at home all right
so lot in the news obviously the media
are going absolutely apoplectic over the
new James Comey book which is supposedly
filled with bombshells
there's only one problem there are no
bombshells in former FBI director james
comey 'he's new book first of all James
called me called this thing a higher
loyalty loyalty to like the money
because if this was all stuff of vital
public import then why exactly did he
wait a year and a book contract before
coming out with it if he wants to
demonstrate that he really is not in it
for the cash that he's really in it
because he just wants to tell the truth
then he likes stormy Daniels could just
give up the money he's not gonna be
doing that anytime soon and the media I
mean they are so over the moon about
this book but they're really trying to
make mountains out of not even mole
hills I mean the stories in this book
are nothing it's all James commis whiney
opinions Chris Wallace I think said up
on Fox News he said this book is
incredibly big and it really is and if
you look at this book and you read the
segments from it it's really just nasty
and petty and stupid that's at least
what I'm getting from it because I'm not
seeing any revelations here I'm not
seeing anything that says to me wow this
is something I didn't know remember
James Comey was fired because President
Trump wanted him to clear him in the
Russia investigation publicly and James
Comey said you're not being investigated
and Trump said we'll say that publicly
and Comey said no and Trump said fine
you're fired
all right that's exactly what happened
and now we're supposed to believe that
something deep in nefarious happened
Comey went on Capitol Hill he testified
that Trump had obstructed his Russia
investigation in any way Trump just got
rid of him because Trump apparently was
unhappy with him that Comey would not
publicly say the truth which is that
Trump was not the target of the
investigation or even a subject of the
investigation at the time well here are
some of the revelations that the media
are just going nuts over and it's
wall-to-wall coverage of James Comey
book because this was a preset agenda
there's a general point here to be made
about the media that I think is relevant
for people to understand over the last
at least 15 to 20 years most of my life
in in politics and that is the media are
trying to portray it right now as though
we live in a trump centric universe and
then we live in this this universe where
everything revolves around Trump every
story has to be refracted through the
prism of Trump that's not true okay we
actually live in a heliocentric universe
but the Helios is not Trump the Helios
is the media everything is about the
media all stories are refracted through
the prism of the media Trump is
refracted through the prism of the media
Trump is a satellite orbiting the media
right the media are they are the grand
arbiters of what it is that you see and
what it is that you hear and all of the
politicians are speaking to against or
through the media and this has never
been clearer than it is with regard to
how they are treating the economy stuff
because the Comey stuff is not even a
blip
okay this book is not even a blip and
this is not me coming at it from a he's
a political hack and all this kind of
this is just like as objective as I can
be about this if there been a bombshell
in here I would been happy to report it
to you there is nothing
his Robert De Niro has Al Capone in the
Untouchables he's got nothing there
there's nothing here nothing zero things
he says let's go through some of these
supposed and revelations in here first
of all he's at an interview with George
Stephanopoulos it's supposed to air on
Sunday and here are some of the grand
revelations again this is all
petty nonsense here's Stephanopoulos
with Komi no graphic did you get I think
as graphic as I needed to be I started
tell him about the allegation was that
he had been involved with prostitutes in
a hotel in Moscow in 2013 during a visit
for the Miss Universe pageant and that
the Russians had filmed the episode and
he interrupted very defensively and
started talking about it you know do I
look like a guy who needs hookers and I
assumed he was asking that rhetorically
I didn't answer that and I just moved on
and explained sir I'm not saying that we
credit this not saying we believe it we
just thought it very important that you
know did you tell him you thought it
wasn't true or you didn't know if it was
true or not I never said I don't believe
it because I couldn't say one way or
another how weird was that breathing
really weird I was almost an out-of-body
experience for me I was floating above
myself looking down saying you're
sitting here briefing the incoming
president United States about
prostitutes in Moscow says he may want
me to investigate it to prove that it
didn't happen and then he says something
that distracted me because he said you
know if there's even a 1% chance my wife
thinks that's true that's terrible
and I and I remember thinking how could
your wife think there's a 1% chance
you're with prostitutes peeing on each
other in Moscow I'm a flawed human being
but there's literally zero chance that
my wife would think that was true so
what kind of marriage to what kind of
man is your wife think there's only a 99
percent chance you didn't do that and I
said to him sir when he started talking
about it I may order you to investigate
that I said sir that's up to you but
you'd want to be careful about that
because it might create a narrative that
were investigating you personally and
second it's very difficult to prove
something didn't happen
did you believe his denial honestly I
never thought these words would come out
of my mouth but I don't know whether the
current president knighted States was
with prostitutes peeing on each other in
Moscow in 2013 it's possible okay that
is such a this is such nonsense
stupidity okay there's no evidence
whatsoever to suggest that the Donald
Trump was having prostitutes pee on him
in Moscow honest to god if the president
wanted to the president
and have to pay anyone to pee on him
he's got the media doing it to him
full-time for free right here George
Stephanopoulos is peeing on him okay
doesn't need Russian prostitutes doing
it for him but James Comey sitting there
and going you know it's just insane that
the President of the United States would
ask me to investigate this thing and
then in the same breath like literally
in the same sentence saying I don't know
if it's true though I mean it's possible
well if it's possible then what are you
complaining about him saying he wants it
investigated to get to the bottom of it
like you think it's sort of true and
you're not the only one like Seth Meyers
goes on TV last night
and he says well clearly if Trump was
asking about it then probably Trump was
peed on by Russian prostitutes which
doesn't make any sense at all but it's
amazing the entire media that went nuts
over the P tape for literally months is
now deeply concerned that Donald Trump
wanted that investigated and himself
cleared of it because how could he how
could he do such a thing well maybe it's
because you guys kept saying P tape over
and over for weeks probably it's that I
hear Seth Meyers making a fool of
himself oh my god it's real if you knew
for a fact that P tape definitely didn't
exist that's like me saying can you make
sure there isn't a tape of me in 1994
doing Thunder Road to karaoke and then
barfing and then slipping on the barf
and farting okay this is so stupid
again if President Trump actually
thought you were guilty of this would he
want the FBI looking into it the logic
doesn't even make any sort of basic
sense but because the media are invested
in making Trump into a mockery they're
going to say P tape over and over and
over and over again until all this is
over Comey of course makes a bunch of
other allegations in the book and again
he talked the Stephanopoulos about this
here's some more of what he had to say
to George Stephanopoulos in his big
primetime interview that's coming on
Sunday whew it's earth-shattering except
for the fact that all this is really
about as Nate silver put it not a man of
the right right Nate silver says his
book shouldn't be called the higher
loyalty it should be called the higher
royalty here is a year's James Comey
talking with Stephanopoulos as an
electrons first question was to confirm
that it had no impact on the election
and then the conversation to my surprise
moved into a PR conversation about how
the Trump team would position this and
what they could say about this they
actually started talking about drafting
a press release with us still sitting
there and the reason that was so
striking to me is that that's just not
done that the intelligence community
does intelligence the White House does
PR and spin okay so are we supposed to
believe that it's like a big deal that
Trump doesn't know how government works
congratulations he doesn't know how
government works
Wow you've solved the Rubik's Cube here
you solved the riddle President Trump is
not an expert on how the government
works yep shocker to everyone I'm sure
everyone involved is just sitting around
with their draw slack to the floor what
utter nonsense and silliness by the way
Comey said that he did not brief
President Trump on the fact that this
Fusion GPS dossier was originally funded
by Democratic Hilary Club by Democrats
and Hillary Clinton he didn't reveal
that to Trump because presumably he
didn't want Trump tweeting that out that
if he had known that the dossier was
funded by the Democrats he just would
have said the dossier was funded by the
Democrats and then that would have
immediately undercut the credibility of
the dossier so he said he didn't think
it was relevant for Trump to know that
okay so it's relevant for Trump to know
about stupid allegations with no
evidence to back them about a P tape
with Russians peeing on each other and
him but it's deep but it's not important
at all for Trump to know that those
allegations were being compiled by a
firm being paid by Hillary Clinton
completely irrelevant
yeah no commis not a political actor at
all okay here are some of the other
allegations that Comey makes in the book
that are supposed to be earth-shattering
so he says that he says that he received
a call from John Kelly who's then the
head of the Department of Homeland
Security and now the White House chief
of staff and Kelly was quote-unquote
emotional over how Comey was fired Comey
writes that Kelly was sick about the
situation and intended to quit in
protest well he didn't did he
he's still around is he not he is the
White House chief of staff
so apparently who cares also I love this
a couple other bombshells apparently
Comey ridicules Trump for being shorter
than he anticipated and described Trump
is having half white the bright white
half moons beneath his eyes he also
argued that Trump's ties were too long
according to the Associated Press and
suggested the one he shook Trump's hand
he evaluated his hand size he said they
might have been a little bit small but
no real not not that much smaller than
normal
yeah that's not petty and ridiculous
that's not petty and silly no this is
deep stuff that we all have to know
about it
James Comey is a man of honor he's a man
of deep honor sure he blew the Hillary
investigation sure he botched everything
he touched since May that's basically
like January 2016 but no he's a man of
honor don't you understand he's not out
there grandstanding you know getting
million-dollar advances and then going
on national TV to talk about Trump's
hand sighs no no he is a man of deep and
abiding respect and honor for
institutions now there are a couple of
things in this book that are worth
discussing and I'll discuss them in just
a second first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at the u.s. CCA so
attention gun-owners I have a very big
announcement that you're not gonna want
to miss do you want a brand new gotten
for free well you're in luck because the
u.s. CCA is adding serious bang to your
April they are giving away a different
gun every single day to a law-abiding
citizen that's right you could win a
brand-new gun every day this week and
it's not just one gun you get up to 17
chances to win your gun daily it's only
for a limited time don't get left behind
just go to defend my family now 1.com to
reveal which gun you could take home
tomorrow defend my family now 1.com is
in 1911 or maybe that new Sig Sauer
you've had your eye on all I can say is
the today's gun is one you have to see
to believe so go to defend my family now
one calm to see it and get entered to
win it and hurry because the gun of the
day disappears at midnight don't kick
yourself tomorrow because you missed the
gun you want today go to defend my
family now one calm to get up to
seventeen chances to win a new gun every
day this week again the USC CA you
should be working with them anyway they
provide you legal protection they
provide you educational resources go to
defend my family now one calm to
register defend my family now one calm
to register and make sure that you have
17 shots at getting the gun of the day
over to defend my family now one calm
armed citizens who are law-abiding make
the country a better place and you can
be one of them go to defend my family
now one calm right now okay so other
revelations in the James Comey book
include this one this is just what a
what a self-serving a sad-sack James
Comey is my goodness okay this is a
legit quote from the book Comey writes
that Obama President Obama sat alone
with him in the Oval Office in late
November and told him quote I picked you
to be FBI director because of your
integrity and your ability I want you to
know that nothing buffett has happened
in the last year to change my view on
the verge of tears Comey told Obama boy
were those words I needed to hear I'm
just trying to do the right thing I know
Obama said I know oh my
God really really seeing that Ohama said
that I'm a good guy he said I'm a good
guy I was I'm I almost cried when he
said I was a good guy yeah okay
other things that are hilarious in this
book so apparently Comey says in the
book that he would that when he revealed
late in the election right ten days
before the election that Hillary Clinton
they were reopening the email
investigation because Hillary's emails
were found on the computer of the of the
accused child pornographer Anthony
Weiner that when that happened Comey
considered the polling data or he might
have considered the polling data you
thought Hillary was so far ahead it
won't matter if I reveal this stuff now
but if you had thought that the election
really close maybe would have held until
after the election yeah that this is
really a guy who's just full-on credible
I have to say he was playing one of the
great scams I have ever seen I mean this
is a usual suspect level scam hey this
is this is a the sting level scam it's
an amazing scam how good is this scam
James Comey may have cost Hillary
Clinton the election hey James Comey and
his late breaking news in the election
might have cost Hillary Clinton the
presidency and now the only people who
love him are the people who voted for
Hillary Clinton that is an unbelievable
scam I mean boy oh boy if I could have
thought of that one cost Hillary the
election and then turn on Trump and get
all of the people who hated you to buy
your book and declare you the most
honest man in politics what a beautiful
scam that is so apparently he also said
in the book that as a prosecutor he used
to tell juries trying to evaluate a
witness that you can't cherry-pick you
can't say things like he's saying that's
about Trump I like these things he said
but on this he's a dirty rotten liar you
got to take it all together so you got a
rap Trump up into a ball and then take
it all at face value okay then why
didn't you that with Hillary Clinton why
did you pick and choose which facts you
were to go over about Hillary Clinton
why is that a thing
by the way there is a serious question
as to whether James Comey has violated
his FBI review rules right he's actually
f but there are prohibited disclosures
by the FBI FBI employees shall not
disclose information that relates to the
substantive merits of any ongoing or
open investigation or case so all of the
said James Comey may still be in
violation of law so we'll have to see
how all of that shakes out well
President Trump has now responded to
James Comey and it is indeed hilarious
so here's President Trump's response he
tweeted out a couple of things about
James Comey and
if you just think that America you know
somehow we ended up in the alternative
reality where Biff actually used the
sports book to bet on games and then
married Marty McFly's mom and somehow we
ended up in that timeline you would
probably would not be wrong because I
mean this is a real thing that is
happening right now today okay the
President of the United States tweeted
this out first of all you have the
former FBI director accusing the
President of the United States of
possibly having been peed on by Russian
prostitutes even though he has no
evidence of it and then jabbering
ridiculously about the president's hand
sighs and then you got the president so
the president sitting around the Oval
Office and mr. president just just look
commis imploding
okay just let him implode it's fine
everything's good just stop just that
but no president Trump has his head so
here's the president wrote pretty
fantastic Jim's coming is a proven
liquor and the liar virtually everyone
in Washington thought he should be fired
for the terrible job he did until he was
in fact fired he leaked classified
information for which he should be
prosecuted
he lied to Congress under oath he is a
weak and untruthful slimeball who was as
time has proven a terrible director of
the FBI his handling of the crooked
Hillary Clinton case capital C and the
events surrounding it will go down as
one of the worst batch jobs of history
it was my great honor to fire James
Comey boom roasted they didn't actually
say boom roasted but he probably should
have because I mean come on first of all
I'd slimeball untruthful slime balls
pretty good slimeball and Pete ape is
gonna be a fantastic morning show
somewhere it's gonna be like welcome to
the morning show with slimeball and Pete
ape it's just this is our politics now
president the United States being
accused of Pete Apes former FBI director
being an untruthful slimeball pretty
pretty spectacular stuff Abraham Lincoln
looks on and weeps but you know this is
the country that we have and we've
brought it upon it we bought the ticket
we take the ride my friends you know
this is the way it works it wouldn't
have been you know in some ways it
wouldn't we went to got in this with
Hillary we've gotten some pretty crappy
stuff with Hillary but I will say it
wouldn't been this much fun this is
pretty this pretty wild so the best part
of this is John Brennan who's the former
head at the CIA right John Brennan was a
political hack just par excellence so he
responds to the Hughes the director of
the Central Intelligence Agency under
Obama and he responds we
this this is I love this so much so
Donald Trump calls James Comey an
untruth the slimeball and John Brennan
fights back with this he says your caki
stock recei is collapsing after its
lamentable journey as the greatest
nation in history has known we have the
opportunity to emerge from this
nightmare stronger and more committed to
ensuring a better life for all Americans
including those you have so tragically
deceived so ack-ack its accuracy by the
way is a is a system of government which
is run by the worst least qualified or
most unscrupulous citizens for those you
don't know but I just like I love that
the Donald Trump calls Comey a liar a
leaker and a slimeball and John Brennan
replies with caki stock receipt and
lamentable pretty spectacular
and there are a lot of memes going
around this morning on Twitter and
people saying things like me at the
drycleaners
why is my dry cleaning late the dry
cleaner your cactus na Christie is
collapsing after it's lamentable journey
oh the ego the pretension the stupidity
I'm not sure I've ever seen anything
quite like it it is it is pretty
spectacular in virtually every way and
again all of this is just getting more
ridiculous so there's a report yesterday
and just shows how the media is
malfeasance and all of us there's a
report yesterday that President Trump
had had supposedly fathered an
illegitimate child there's no evidence
that he fathered an illegitimate child
okay there's something called American
media Inc they owned the National
Enquirer and they allegedly paid 30
grand with an MD no Sid Juden who was a
doorman for Trump for the rumor about
Trump having an affair with his maid in
the 1980s and fathering a child with her
apparently okay so here's the problem
nobody is able to have been able to
determine if the rumor is true so
instead what the media do is they
reports that the National Enquirer paid
30 grand for the story and then killed
it so they're saying the real story is
that Trump and his friends kill lots of
stories about Trump but what they're
really reporting obviously is the
salacious rumor that President Trump has
a little Trump running around somewhere
that we don't know about my only
question is whether this is the same
maid who had an affair with Arnold
Schwarzenegger because that would be a
pretty good record right if you have a
kid by Schwarzenegger and a kid by Trump
and nobody knows about it that's pretty
spectacular but it is worth noting that
this Dorman's ex-wife said quote he's
infamous for making up stories he's seen
the chupacabra he's seen Bigfoot one of
our friends who passed away he saw him
two walking down the street but they're
printing this
anyway demonstrating once again that
this is you know this is what the media
are the media are just a bunch of rumour
mongers
who are seeking to get President Trump
and this is why they're on Comey and
this weather on this no wonder people
don't believe the the quote-unquote fake
news ok so meanwhile something intensely
stupid was happening in Congress and
this I I have some serious comments
about Cory Booker is just an awful
senator he was a bad mayor he was a guy
who grande I mean talk about people who
grandstand talk about egos in politics
you have to talk about Cory Booker a guy
who did the whole food stamp challenge
where he pretended the people on food
stamps are living only on the food they
get through food stamps which is not
true it is called Supplemental Nutrition
Assistance Program supplemental as in
like beyond the food that you already
buy the Cory Booker did that he was
famous for posturing and grandstanding
he's very pro-israel and he was mayor of
New Jersey now of course he's very
anti-israel as the senator from New
Jersey
and Cory Booker of course is the guy who
also did his did his famous kind of
screaming routine who was it against the
one where he had the one where he's like
making the funny hands the jazz hands
and he went crazy on somebody in
Congress and it was and it was really
ridiculous well now he's doing it again
this time it's with Mike Pompeo so Mike
Pompeo who's the former head of the CIA
and now is being nominated for the
Secretary of State position he is he's
brought up on charges by Cory Booker and
Cory Booker asks him the most ridiculous
question I've ever seen asked in
Congress by anyone at any time ever
which is saying a lot because Congress
is filled with people of low IQ cory
booker man he takes the cake here's cory
booker asking Mike Pompeo I kid you not
about what he thinks about gay sex I am
not kidding this is a thing that
happened and is now in the Congressional
Record the same congressional record
that hosts debates between Daniel
Webster and his opponents has Cory
Booker asking Mike Pompeo what he thinks
who sodomy no joke here it is I believe
it's a you believe that gay sex is a
perversion yes or no senator if I if I
can if you yes or no if you believe that
gay sex is a perversion because it's
what you said here senator not your
speeches yes or no do you believe gay
sex is a perversion that I'm gonna give
you the same answer I just gave you
previously my respect for every
individual regardless of the sexual
orientation it's the same have you seen
Brokeback Mountain did you cry did you
make a weird face when he Fletcher and
Jake Gyllenhaal were going at it
mr. presumptive
poor Terry did you like moonlight were
you a little turned on during that beach
scene hmm
because if not I'm not sure you can be
Secretary of State
did you watch call me by your name in
slow motion did you did you see the
scene with the peach what did you think
of it hmm like visit what in the world
what is the world like this is a thing
that's happening now no matter how crazy
you think the Republicans are everybody
I'm talking Republicans now no matter
how crazy you think Republicans are
folks this is like beyond ok it's
correct it's it's supremely crazy so I
got into a bait about this with a friend
of mine named Jane Costin over at Vox so
it what's funny about this is the Jane
originally if you'll recall a few months
back were a pretty pretty nasty piece
about for the New York Times but being a
genial sort of fellow I reached out now
we're pretty friendly Jane is a lesbian
and she was very much in favor of this
line of questioning and so I was
wondering what in the world is it like
why does it matter what exactly Mike
Pompeo thinks of gay sex like does he
have to watch gay porn in order to be in
order for hit like show us how much you
like gay sex mr. mister if you want me
to vote for your confirmation you are
going to have to show me how much you
enjoy subscribing to Playgirl right now
show me your subscription sir sir okay
so why exactly is this relevant so Jane
I was trying to make the argument that
as a public official Mike Pompeo should
feel good about gay sex because he's
gonna have to defend the rights of gay
people this is I think a very a very
foolish argument first of all this is
plainly religious bigotry okay virtually
every religious person in the United
States ever deeply religious person
every Bible believing person in the
United States believes that homosexual
activities is in an Orthodox Jew I
believe homosexual activity is a sin now
welcome to a free country where I think
the government should not be involved in
anybody sex life I've been a libertarian
on the gay marriage issue longer than
Barack Obama right and and with all of
this I mean I've been I've been saying
since legit 2012 2011 that there should
be a libertarian position from the
government on same-sex marriage
I can believe both things right I
believe lots of things are sinful as a
religious person I think that it's
sinful for you to be a racist I also
think that you have a right to be a
racist in the United States because we
have something called free speech I
think that it's sinful for I think I
think lots of things in life are sinful
I think that it is sinful for you to
marry your aunt but do I have like a
cific you know real concern about people
marrying their aunts in terms of public
policy not like especially I don't think
it's a major issue on the plate right
now I think that it's sinful to take
drugs but I'm pretty libertarian when it
comes to marijuana for example so again
this is how most religious people in the
United States think they think that
there's a difference between what i
religiously believe to be a sin and what
the government should police and what
cory booker should be asking here is
what is your perspective on how gay
people abroad should be treated and Mike
Pompeo just said they should be treated
with the same respect accorded to
anybody else right which is perfectly
acceptable what I think Jane was getting
at and what Booker is actually getting
at is something a little bit deeper
which is their suggestion is that they
don't believe you that I don't believe
that they don't believe me if I say that
I think that homosexual activity is a
sin but I also think it's a free country
your feel you're free to think I'm an
idiot and you're free to disobey me and
you're free to do whatever you want I
mean I can't give you orders you're an
adult do whatever the hell you want
right that if I say that I must not be
sincere if I think something's a sin in
order for me to believe that you have a
right to something I have to believe
that thing is good this is a really
dangerous mentality it's the same
mentality that on flip side says on the
left that there is no First Amendment
except for rhetoric we like right
because obviously everyone believes that
right the the only way that you should
agree with the First Amendment free
speech right to say some things if you
agree with the thing being said that of
course destroys the concept of the First
Amendment the whole purpose of freedom
is that you have freedom to do things
that I may not like that's the whole
purpose of freedom if we all did the
same things you wouldn't need freedom
freedom would be irrelevant but that's
not the question being asked so the real
implication here the real implication of
course is that if you're a religious
Christian you cannot be the Secretary of
State
that's what cory booker really is saying
he's saying that if you're a religious
christian and you believe homosexual
activities are sin even if you're
libertarian governmentally even if you
think that the United States should
defend the rights of people all over the
world on these issues you really don't
believe it because secretly deep down
you have animus toward gay sex you don't
like watching gay people go at it or you
think it's sinful right this is it is a
religious that's right it is prescribed
by the Constitution of the United States
what cory booker is doing here right now
is a religious test he is saying if you
are a religious christian and you
believe the bible you cannot be
Secretary of State that's what this says
now the great irony of this the thing
that's really incredible about this is
Cory Booker then goes on to question
Mike Pompeo about Frank Gaffney and
Bridget gab and Brigitte Gabriel so
Frank Gaffney runs the senator for
security policy very very hawkish very
hard on Islam and radical Islam in
particular Brigitte Gabriel runs
something called act for America which
is also a group that is opposed to the
influence of Sharia law and radical
Islam now I may not agree with
everything that Frank and Brigitte say
but the idea that anyone who's ever
associated with Frank and Brigitte is
somehow guilty of some grave sin is
simply ridiculous Brigitte Gabriel as a
Christian Lebanese woman who was forced
to live for years in like an
eight-by-ten bunker because of Islamic
terrorism in Lebanon so she was a pretty
good case to make it against Islamic
terror but there's another thing here
that's really funny listen to cory
booker go after pompeii on his
association with gaffney and and gabriel
were you silent in your position of
authority against these words that are
violative of the american constitution
were you silent with him senator my
record on this is unambiguous
I served in it then that's that's a
response you did not say anything to
call out his remarks what about Brigitte
Gabriel do you know her I do and someone
who has been who runs organization that
has been considered a hate group by the
anti-defamation league in the Southern
Poverty Law Center have you ever were
you silent did you ever call her out on
her remarks they were hateful or bigoted
said I've spoken to a number of groups
and my I believe my record with respect
to tolerance and here's the part that's
really funny okay so what he's asking
about specifically I looked up what the
the ADL says about Brigitte and what
they said about Frank they basically
said the same thing about Brigitte did
they say about Frank what they say about
both is both of them have said that you
can't really be a good American citizen
if you are a if you are a fundamentalist
Muslim if you are a religious Muslim you
can't be a good American citizen now
that is something with which I disagree
depending on how you define religious
Muslim if you're defining a religious
Muslim as radical Muslim then sure if
you're defining religious Muslim is
somebody goes to mosque then of course
not
but here's the part that's hilarious
about what Booker is doing here what
Booker just said to Mike Pompeo is if
you are a religious Christian you cannot
be Secretary of State because you
believe that homosexual activity is a
sin but you also cannot be Secretary of
State if you say that members of a
particular religion might not make good
citizens you see a little bit of a
contradiction here so in other words
cory booker says that if you say that
islam is not compatible with democracy
then that is big
which you know might be sort of like a
quarter to half true okay but then he
says if you're a Christian then that's
not compatible with democracy so how is
this working exactly how's this working
exactly but it shows the extremism of
the left again if President Trump wants
to get reelected all he has to do is
somehow convince the left to nominate
Cory Booker who is a complete nutjob
Ted Joe Biden is is obviously
considering the White House run in 2020
and he is making noises saying like well
I'm not gonna run if there's somebody
else on the Democratic side who can win
and then of course he's gonna run he's
gonna say there's no one else on the
Democratic side who can win the big
problem for the Democrats is that Joe
Biden might be the only guy who really
has a credible shot of beating Trump it
ain't Cory Booker it ain't Kirsten
Gillibrand it's certainly in Kamala
Harris all three of those people are too
busy ensconced in their own identity
politics of stupidity and alienating
vast swaths of America to ever win the
presidency so here is Biden basically
watching his presidential run I'm really
hoping that some other folks step up I
think we have some really good people
rev I know Barack always asked me that
question and he said what's going to
make the decision I got to be able to
look in the mirror and if I walk away no
I'm not walking away because I'm afraid
or I'm worried about losing or that I
just don't want to take on the
responsibility I got to walk away
knowing that it is there's somebody who
can do it and can win because if we got
a win we've got a win in 2020 okay so
Biden obviously thinks he's the best
shot at doing that and the bigger is the
problem for Biden Biden may be too
moderate for the modern Democratic Party
he could be he might be too moderate he
might not be identity politics enough he
might not be wildly crazily anti-trump
enough Ted Lou's a congressman from out
here in California he says listen if we
take the house we're gonna go full scale
investigation balls-to-the-wall right
wall-to-wall investigations of the
president Trump nothing would be better
calibrated to win Trump reelection than
extremism on the part of Democrats
erican voters have an ax flexion point
this November it can change the makeup
of Congress and give Democrats subpoena
power and then we will conduct real
investigation okay if this is what the
direction the Democrats want to go then
Trump really does have a shot again the
Cory Booker Democratic Party is not a
winning party now I'm gonna get to the
mailbag in just a second for that
to have to go over to daily wire calm so
check out daily wire calm got the rest
of the show live ask your questions
right now right if you subscribe in like
the next 10 seconds then you get to ask
me questions live right now by going to
our daily wired chatroom and asking
questions in the window and then we'll
answer those questions live on air for
your listening and viewing enjoyment so
check that out you also get the rest of
Clavin show live and Michael Knowles's
show live and all the other goodies were
putting behind the paywall you get you
get all of that plus if you want the
annual subscription to get this the very
greatest and beverage vessels leftist
here's hot or cold tumbler $9.99 a month
gets you this the very greatest in all
vessels that hold beverages so check
that out as well it's cheaper than the
monthly and you get this cup to show all
your friends and take them off so that's
pretty fun if you just want to listen
later go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube please subscribe please live
this review we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
all righty so time for some mailbag so
let's jump right in alaya says hey Ben
I'm big fan of the show and the leftist
year's Cup oh yes
aren't we all he says I was wondering
what are your thoughts on the American
Bar Association and if you think they
are to blame for high legal fees in
America well any guild is to blame for
elevated legal fees one of the big
problems in the United States is
licensure the problem of suggesting that
every different industry has to be
licensed so in Arizona right now this
big fight over there hairdressers have
to be licensed why in the world should
you have to be licensed to be a
hairdresser like if you if you are a
girl you've been dressing your own hair
since the time you were very very young
okay so I'm not sure why exactly you
need a government license in order to
cut somebody's hair they it's just it's
just ridiculous the same thing is true
in the law okay the law school I went
there you know I went to the top law
school in America by most standards okay
and that law school the first year was
useful and the last two years were a
waste of time and you learn more in
studying for the bar than you actually
did anywhere else and then you didn't
learn anything you really needed to know
until you actually started working for a
law firm and drawing up contracts and
doing all that stuff
I think apprenticeships would go a lot
further than the guild system they have
where you're licensed to become a member
of the bar for example Christopher says
I want to ask your advice because you're
someone who has supported a spouse
through medical school I returned to
school after my service as an army
officer to pursue an MD I recently got
married both of us one want kids as I'm
sure you can relate to we are now both
in our early thirties and we're not
getting any younger as a man I feel like
I have an obligation my wife and future
children to financially support them but
that is not feasible for me for a very
long time I won't even begin my
residency for another six years I'm torn
between continuing to pursue my career
goals or my family goals
thank you for your advice my wife and I
listen to you every day together well
first of all my great my real suspicion
is that there is a way for you and your
wife to have children while you are in
medical school even if you are supposed
to be the the breadwinner and that is
you know these student loans are
available there are people who are
living on student loans who have kids if
you are an MD it's pretty easy to get a
student loan considering that they know
you're gonna be making money on the
other end of the MD so I would urge you
to look at all the financial solutions
available I'd also urge you to go to
your local church and talk with people
about the possibility of being given a
loan you know I know that if there were
people in my synagogue who need a loan
to go to medical school and they wanted
to have a kid that I'd be looking at
giving them a loan you know that the
charity is is definitely something
that's worthwhile here I don't
you should miss your childbearing years
to go to medical school but I mean
another possibility is that you have
kids right now you work for a few years
build up a little nest egg and then go
to medical school that's a possibility
too I and I think life presents you a
number of ways of slicing this
particular egg and I think that it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be worth
giving up you know the most important
thing you can do in life which is having
children rearing them because you have
career aspirations again I don't think
they're mutually exclusive
josh has haben do you think we'll get
involved in Syria or is it a nothing
burger love the show also love my bowl
and bran sheets well I'm glad that you
enjoy your bowl and bran sheets Josh
they are indeed fantastic do I think
we'll get involved in Syria I think that
we'll be involved in Syria is slightly
more than we are currently I don't think
we're going to full-scale war in Syria I
don't think there's a public support for
it I don't think there's a good strategy
for it I think the idea of toppling
Assad would require enormous amounts of
manpower money blood I don't think
anybody wants that I think the best we
can do is try to check Iranian ambition
in the region and let our regional
allies do some heavier work around the
Mideast in order to minimize their
influence Kirk says what do you think
the pros and cons of the flat tax and
fair tax are which one do you prefer so
the fair tax from what I recall
depending on the there are different
fair tax proposals but the fair tax is
essentially a national sales tax it gets
rid of the income tax the flat tax says
there's an income tax but you but it is
flat across the board I tend to be more
in favor of the fair tax I like the idea
of a national sales tax because being
taxed for per transaction on consumption
is easier to monitor and then it's also
up to you what you wanted with your
money if you want to buy things they're
gonna be taxed on it if you don't want
to buy things then you won't be taxed on
it the same thing is not true of income
tax the the idea of having to turn over
to the government how much money I owe
on a regular basis if you go to limit
let's put this way if you could
eliminate either the sales tax or the
income tax I would eliminate the income
tax in the state of California we have
both I would eliminate the income tax
because I think it is much easier for
people to play class warfare with the
income tax than it is for them to play
class warfare with the sales tax because
rich people do buy more stuff than poor
people okay Kenny says hey Ben I was
wondering your thoughts on the
prenuptial agreement I've heard both
sides if you do want your marriage is
doomed or if you're gonna be together
forever who cares your thoughts
thank you huge fan I'm not against
prenuptial agreements we basically
Judaism almost mandates then that's what
a ketubah is right a ketubah is a is a
marital document that actually includes
the divorce amount right that if I
divorce my wife it actually says in my
ketubah home
money I owe her in fact there's a really
funny story there's there in the Jewish
community they're sort of a particularly
in the Sephardic Jewish community
there's sort of a tradition of haggling
over the amount of money in the ketubah
right like how much you and you haggle
usually not with your wife because that
would be real awkward but with her
parents very often and so I remember I
went to talk but one day I was up in in
Sacramento which is where my in-laws
live and my in-laws my my father-in-law
comes up to me is right before I was
getting married
and he says you know Ben is Israelis Ben
and I have to a very serious
conversation with you and I said okay
and he says I thought okay something
Bad's coming here and he says I just
want to talk to you about the amount in
the ketubah I said I don't care what you
put in there I'm not getting divorced so
whatever you want like men doesn't I
said no no really what do you want to
put in there and I said well as I said I
don't care put a hundred million dollars
and he goes oh my god is it worth 100
million dollars put ten million dollars
so that's what's in the ketubah is ten
million dollars but I'm not anti
prenuptial agreement I think that
thinking through the consequences of
your actions early is probably not a
terrible idea and it depends I mean it's
the mentality going in I think that if
you say to your wife or your prospective
wife listen I want you to be guaranteed
a certain amount of money if things
should go south this is actually my
guarantee to you that things will go
well it depends what you're looking for
in the prenup if what you're looking for
in the prenup is you get off scot-free
then I think your wife has a reason to
be suspicious if what you're putting in
the prenup is here's a liquidated
damages provision that makes this you
know pretty likely to be locked in then
I think that it's not a terrible idea by
any stretch of the imagination let's see
it says Janice what would you recommend
is the best personal finance book to
piggyback off of that what are your
thoughts on separate bank accounts for
married couples thanks for taking the
time to answer my questions so I do not
have a separate bank account for my wife
I trust my wife with our finances and
I'm not concerned she's gonna be
stealing our money also I think that
full transparency is good in marriage
when it comes to finances having
separate bank accounts seems to me a
mistake if you can't trust somebody
enough to handle money with you you
can't trust them enough to raise
children with you as far as the best
personal finance book I really think
that a lot of what Dave Ramsey says is
really terrific I think Dave Ramsey's
program is quite good and I know a lot
of people been helped by Dave Ramsey's
program particularly brian says I read
an article on The Daily wire about South
Carolina trying to leave the USA if
second amendment is repealed
what is the chance this
happens and if they're successful in
passing that bill what other states will
follow well you know I don't know they
could presumably pass a bill now to do
that but the Civil War basically
answered the question as to whether
states can secede from the union if they
feel that their rights have been
violated by the way the Second Amendment
is never gonna be repealed the repeal of
an amendment requires two-thirds of
states three-fifths two-thirds of
Congress and three-fifths of all states
to to go along with it you're not gonna
get 30 states to go along with repealing
the Second Amendment so it really is not
a worry Tyler says what's your opinion
on property taxes do you think they
violate the founders idea of owning
property since in some states who are
essentially renting your property from
the government yeah I'm anti property
tax I'm anti virtually all forms of
taxation I think sales tax is probably
the only kind that it's the least
objectionable kind in other words but
the idea that I'm supposed to keep
paying taxes on property that I bought
ten years ago fifteen years ago as
though I'm renting from the government I
think that's just absurd I think it's
ridiculous Chase's - the other day he
stated that the Republicans may never
control all the branches of government
again what made you say that thanks
again for the great show well I think
frankly that everybody was shocked that
Donald Trump won the presidency is very
likely the Republicans lose the house in
2018 and the upcoming generation of
Millennials is really really
anti-republican something like 55 21
Democrat / Republican that is not a
great indicator for the future of
republicanism and I was saying that a
little bit hyperbolically I think that
the chances that Republicans will never
control all branches of government again
is low I don't I I never think it's the
end of the world but I think that the
near future does not look particularly
bright for Republicans on the federal
scale it looks better on the state level
Sean says hey Ben do you think
Christians will go to heaven yes so the
Jewish perspective on heaven is that if
you fulfill seven basic Commandments
then you go to heaven and these
Commandments are really really basic
it's like don't kill people don't steal
don't commit adultery don't don't cut
flesh from a living animal believe in
God establish courts of law it's it's
all very very basic stuff they're called
the shovel midslope but they know off
the 7 the 7 commandments that were given
to the sons of noah and in judaism
everybody who is not a son of abraham is
considered a son of noah so if you're if
you're outside Benet yes or Al or son of
Jacob then you are considered a son of
Noah and subject to those particular
laws ok brad says what is your position
on the various
official positions taken against animals
in Leviticus as an Orthodox Jew why
would you not follow these things this
is a serious question as I read the
Bible meaning am i pro or anti sacrifice
so there's a lively debate inside Jewish
commentators over what exactly the
purpose of the animal sacrifices were in
the temple so Rambam had Maimonides he
says when the purpose of animal
sacrifices were to wean people away from
animal sacrifices the basically pagan
societies embraced animal sacrifices and
really liked animal sacrifices and so
what the Torah did was it said instead
of you performing animal sacrifices to
propitiate the gods instead of that what
it's going to be is that we're gonna
regularize this stuff it's not gonna be
used slaughtering animals in your
backyard you have to go to a centralized
site that is run by priests who are
worshipping God and then you're going to
have to be thinking about your
relationship with God every time an
animal is slaughtered in order for us to
make this non holy activity holy and
that's that's Maimonides perspective my
motty's perspective says that in the
future if the temple is really when the
in judaism when the temple is
re-established then it will not then
there may not be animal sacrifices at
all and that's a significant possibility
and then there are people who say that
the whole purpose of these sacrifices is
to remind you that really you've
committed sins that make your life
forfeit and it's only through God's
mercy that you are not being killed
right now and the brutality of animal
sacrifice is supposed to it's not
supposed to be pleasant it's supposed to
be unpleasant it's supposed to be remind
you that you are an animal
unless you unless you supersede your
animalistic instincts and and and become
something more rachel says what is your
favorite Disney Pixar movie well the
best five minutes of a Disney Pixar
movie are the first five minutes of up
Bar None the first of the first five
minutes above are just incredible the
rest of the movies good but I'm not sure
that it holds all the way you know let
me look up a real a really quick list of
all the Disney Pixar films because now I
want to now I want to try to remember
though what all of them are so I thought
inside-out was quite good I liked Toy
Story 3 I thought was really terrific it
means really not a sequels fan but I
thought toys Story 3 was was really
first-rate the just in terms of fun I
thought monsters University was quite
good there's some fun stuff in in
ratatouille probably I'd probably have
to go toy story 3 I'd probably have to
say Toy Story 3 is is my favorite
although again I think toys
is quite good actually not like the
original Toy Story very much how Brayton
says hey Ben I'm a college student in
class the other day my teacher told the
class that we are all illegal immigrants
because our ancestors stole the land
from Native Americans and we have no
legal rights to the land then saying we
have no room to talk if we are against
illegal immigration since I've never
heard that argument before I had no way
to combat the ridiculous statement so I
was wondering how you would respond well
there are a couple of different
responses here so one is sort of the
founding response which is that in order
to stake a claim to a land you have to
have permanent presence on the land and
you have to cultivate it right this is
the Lockean response to property
ownership which is why there is such a
thing in Western in law called the
adverse possession which is if I own a
piece of land and I just leave it fallow
for a hundred years I just buy it leave
it there and you go and you live on it
and you set up a house and then you set
up a farm and you live there for 20
years and I come back and I say what are
you doing on my land that I can't
actually kick you off you have now
adversely possessed the land because
you're cultivating it and I am not so if
Native Americans didn't cultivate the
land in in a way that amounted to a
central ownership then they didn't have
the properties of ownership and land
second of all even if you put that
argument aside which is you know a dicey
argument in some ways then certainly one
thing is true population movement has
been happening forever and many of the
Native American tribes that were present
at the founding of the United States
were actually relatively recent arrivals
in that part of the United States so
native tribes dispossessed each other
the native tribes during certain
portions of American history
dispossessed settlers settlers
dispossessed American tribes that's not
to say that brutal treatment of Native
Americans was justified in any way what
it is to say is that if we're gonna
pretend that land is not transferred
between peoples then that is silly and
sovereign governments do have the right
to push people to to to set their
borders sovereign governments have a
right to set their borders and then the
question becomes can you defend it
alright so if you're not willing to
defend it then you're not defending it
on a practical level but the question is
to whether the United States has a right
to defend its border because Native
Americans were incapable of defending
their borders against the original
American settlers I don't see really how
that follows right there's two questions
one is the moral and one is the
practical on a practical on a moral
level they're on a moral level there are
two questions one is is it immoral to
dispossessed people of their land as a
general rule the answer is generally yes
the second question is is is this
unprecedented in human history or is it
the regular way things work practically
speak
the answer is yes and then the third
question is practically speaking Ken
states defend their borders and morally
speaking can they defend their borders
in the answer on both of those is yes
okay one more question let's see santino
says hey Ben I've recently switched my
major from music education to political
science I've been having a real hard
time dealing with this only because the
university I'm attending gave me a full
tuition scholarship for music but I just
don't have a passion for it anymore I'm
stuck in a situation now where I'm gonna
have to pay for college dry cut without
any financial assistance as my parents
do not understand the financial aid
process one bit you were the one who
inspired me to take on this new chapter
in my life well I'm sorry I blew it up
for you dude so I figured I'd reach out
to you for advice on what to do and what
job opportunities are out there for
political science majors like myself
we're currently still in college
thank you for a constant fight for
conservatism and the founding principles
of America you've truly changed my life
well I can't say this I would say that
the the general rule is that you're
gonna make more money being a Poli Sci
major than a music major there are a lot
of very poor music majors Poli Sci
majors you can go into journalism you
can go into law you can go into teaching
you can you can go into accounting or I
mean Poli Sci leaves a lot of doors open
and so you know I think that you'll be
able to make a living but you should
decide what it is about Poli Sci that
you like do you want to work in
government some work outside government
you want to work you know in a place
like Daily wire and then and then
there's a set of steps that you can take
to facilitate your goals and I would
just say keep your eye on the prize and
come up with a plan feel free to email
me by the way and I'm happy to send you
some steps if you send me your goals
like some steps that I think would be
useful for you to take in pursuit of
those goals okay time for some things
that I like and then some things I hate
and then and then that'll be the end of
the week so let's let's go to the things
I like so first off slow clap for
Rosamund Pike so Rosman Pike is the
actress from gone girl you'll remember
and she's speaking to up rocks and chews
asked about the possibility of a female
as James Bond and here's what she said
so what she said was I just right I just
say right in a new story
James Bond is a character that Ian
Fleming created of course the brand has
become bigger and whatever but take one
of the Bond girls and give her her own
story I think the character of James
Bond is a man he is really to have such
a character and a completely independent
series why should a woman sort of get
sloppy seconds why should she have once
been a man and now it has to be played
by a woman why not make her a kick-ass
female agent in her own right and she
said that swapping a woman in two plays
such an iconic ly male role would be to
underestimate a woman entirely there's
nothing really about the James Bond
characters written by Ian Fleming that
resembles a woman
it's very masculine creation so sure
make her an unapologetic unexpected
kick-ass amazing female agent and yes
I'll play her how is this even a
difficult question obviously Rosamund
Pike is right
she must be listening to the bench
Schapiro sure I've been saying this for
years about the James Bond stupidity but
it's amazing that it takes Rosman Pike
to cut through the crap here
well done Rosamund Pike now I'm gonna
see your movies more often because I
like that so much okay other things that
I like so yesterday I played a little
bit of Guys and Dolls for you there's a
little-known musical by the same people
who wrote Guys and Dolls well Frank
Loesser who wrote fries Guys and Dolls
it's called the most happy fella it
really is cyrano de bergerac for people
who don't know when the original cyrano
de bergerac Cyrano de Bergerac is the
story of a of a soldier who has a really
big nose they did a version of this with
called Roxanne with um with Steve Martin
and the and the soldier is a he has a
really big nose he falls in love with
with a woman who he is afraid of wooing
because he is so ugly and so there's
another guy who crawls in love with her
as well and he starts basically using
that guy as a proxy for his own feeling
so he writes love letters and on behalf
of this other guy the woman falls in
love with the love letters of the other
of Cyrano de Bergerac
but she's falling in love with the other
guy because she thinks he's the one
writing them and of course that ends up
being not the reality most happy fella
is a sort of modernized take on that now
in this case there's an older Italian
fellow who falls in love with a waitress
at a diner and invites her out to his
Napa Valley winery and he has sent her a
picture of somebody else who works on
the farm and the first time she meets
him she realizes that he's actually ugly
and and this is what it sounds like
[Music]
so it's it's you know this is the fun
part of the musical it gets very dark in
certain points and again it's a very
modernized version because in the plot
what actually ends up happening with
this woman is she the the guy who he's
using as the stanzin actually sleeps
with her and impregnates her and then
takes off and now the Italian guy has to
decide whether or not he wants her
whether he likes her whether you know
what he thinks of her it's it's really
interesting in a lot of ways and the
woman who the woman who's playing the
lead right here actually ended up
marrying the guy who wrote the musical
Frank Loesser okay time for a couple of
things that I hate all righty so this is
a pretty amazing clip so there is a a
speech at a law school at CU at CU NY
and the associate professor of South
Texas College of Law on Houston Josh
Blackman visited the college to speak on
the topics of originalism of the
importance of free speech on campus and
here is what it looked like when he went
to speak and then the answer is to
change the law
[Music]
okay so this is an amazing thing and it
does demonstrate how insane everybody
has become f the law this is
legitimately law students who are
standing there saying F the law he's
saying the law doesn't allow this and
they say F the law yeah this is this is
the tower and divers left at their
finest F the law at a law school with a
law professor just geniuses of highest
order the future of our country is
bright obviously I mean a final thing
that I hate to joy behar over on the
view she says that the only thing that
saving the country right now is not the
sanity of the people surrounding
President Trump it's not President Trump
it's not Congress it's not the
constitutional structure
it's the sanity of vladimir putin and
kim jeong-hoon here's one of the russian
prime minute one of the guys over there
said we do not do diplomacy by tweet
yeah thank you thank you well okay
that's that's just sheer ridiculous
nonsense the idea that Vladimir Putin
and Jim kim jeong-hoon are the
stabilizers of the universe is insane
Russia came out today and said that
Britain was responsible for the gassing
of people in Syria Britain well you
can't come up with a better story than
that
that's who sanity joy Behar's relying on
makes me question joy may her sanity but
you know I'll have to discuss that with
her when finally they invite me on the
view I mean what the hell guys I was I
was told that my was hold months ago
that this was a possibility are you just
afraid what's the story I'm gonna dare
you an hour I dare you bring it okay
let's do this thing
come on okay fine well now we're at the
weekend and so have yourself a merry
little weekend we will be back here on
Monday with all the latest news I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018